bonsoir jérémie assous merci de répondre
à nos questions la cour qui s'estime
incompétent a jugé ce litige
qu'est ce que ça signifie concrètement
cela signifie que la cour d'appel tout
comme le tribunal de grande instance de
paris a considéré que benjamin griveaux
a tenu des propos en tant que porte
parole du gouvernement et dans ces
conditions comme chacun sait il n'est
pas possible de poursuivre un ministre
pour ses propos pour ses actes devant le
tribunal de grande instance où la cour
d'appel de paris
on peut que le regretter puisque il là
pour moi
il avait tenu ces propos en tant que
futurs candidats à l'élection municipale
de paris et donc il aurait pu en
répondre il a préféré se cacher derrière
cette exception procédural qui est
connue qui nous étaient connus mais on
ne pensait pas qu'ils oseraient ou qui
pense qui tenterait d'échapper aux
débats sur le fond puisque je vous
rappelle que il n'a pas seulement dit
que rt france était un organe de
propagande ressasser son opinion le
président de la république l'avait dit
libre à lui de le penser et de dire
puisque il a le droit de le dire ce qui
était particulièrement diffamatoires et
qu'il l'ait encore c'est que il a dit
que non seulement c'était la propagande
mais il a également considéré et soutenu
que les journalistes qui avaient leur
carte de presse et qui sont les
journalistes rt n'étaient pas des
journalistes
et cela et ne peux pas le dire vous
remarquerez que depuis qu'il n'est plus
porte parole il s'est bien gardé de
réitérer ses propos
certains médias ont indiqué que arte
france a perdu son procès contre
benjamin griveaux est ce qu'on peut
vraiment l'affirmé d'ailleurs là les
décisions qui sont publiques
va ne disait absolument pas que rta
perdu et soutiennent
ce que pouvaient parfaitement ça qu'on
pouvait parfaitement s'attendre que ils
ne sont pas compétents c'est à dire que
ce n'est pas la bonne juridiction qui
est elle ne peut que c'est une
juridiction c'est-à-dire la cour d'appel
judiciaire le tribunal judiciaire de
paris également n'est pas compétent pour
juger un ministre pour des actes qu'il a
commis dans le cadre de ses fonctions
c'est tous puisque c'est encore une
exception française c'est la cour de
justice de la république qui est seule
compétente pour les actes dans le cadre
de l'exercice de leurs fonctions mais où
comme chacun sait également alors que
l'ancien président françois hollande
avait dit qu'il voulait que cette
juridiction d'exception soient supprimés
ainsi que le président de la république
macron une fois élu se garde bien de la
supprimer mais on ne pensait pas que le
que benjamin griveaux fui esquiverait le
débat on pour c'est qu'il assumerait que
il répondrait qu'il nous ferait part de
ses opinions sur le fond et qui nous
démontre ray si oui ou non et pourquoi
il pense que les journalistes d'ayrté ne
sont pas des journalistes
on voit bien que il est incapable de le
démontrer de le soutenir parce que c'est
totalement faux et que dans l'hypothèse
où il allait sur le fond là celui qui
aurait perdu son procès mais puisque ça
semble être l'un des noeuds du problème
comment déterminer si benjamin griveaux
s'exprimait en tant que membre du
gouvernement ou en tant que personnalité
politique ah bah ça c'est le ccc fait
c'est la partie qu'il a été française là
et soutiennent que ils sont ministre 24
heures sur 24 ce qui le lie la ville est
soutenu que dans le cadre de son
émission sa participation à l'émission
c'est à vous une n'était pas ministre
c'était une possibilité c'est un moyen
de défense il l'a saisie
mais pour encore une fois esquiver et
fuir le fou et quels recours possible
devant la justice lorsqu'une partie
prenante estime qu'elle a subi un
préjudice de la part d'un membre du
gouvernement dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions
alors c'est la particule et fo se
souvenait devant le tribunal
administratif pour un certain pour
certains calmes c'est extrêmement
délimité et très complexe soit vous
allez à devant la cour de justice de la
république mais parce que vos
téléspectateurs ne savent sûrement pas
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
répète tant françois hollande que
emmanuel macron avaient dit qu'ils
allaient supprimer entend lorsqu'il
était
ça coulait lorsqu'il était candidat
parce que on ne peut pas pas l'emporter
mais moi vous le vote des spectateurs ne
peuvent pas saisir la cour de justice de
la république pour ce type de dattes et
poursuites donc j'ai un espèce de
monopole qui appartient au ministère
public
donc on voit bien que ça confirme
l'immunité dont bénéficient les membres
du gouvernement on peut l'approuver ou
le critiquer là n'est pas la question
la vraie question qui se posait sur ce
problème c'est est ce que les gens qui
passent leur temps à critiquer rt à dire
que ce sont des officines de propagande
que ce ne sont pas des journalistes
pourquoi esquive-t-il tous est
systématiquement les débats devant les
seules personnes qui sont à leur donner
raison ou tort à savoir les juges
donc on voit bien que nombreux sont les
personnes 1 qui agresse qui attaquent
mais rares voire inexistants sont ceux
qui assument leur propos une fois qu'ils
doivent en répondre devant des
magistrats
merci jérémie assous d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
l'avocat de rt france